[Musique]
on ne peut pas trop le village qu'on
cherche et bénisse les parts ou beaux
jeunes sourds ya comme un grand sage qui
veille sur la ville celle où il est né
et où il au grade
la maison de son enfance est un petit
musée que tamara fnath aux vans lasse
jamais de faire visiter les mieux placés
car youri gagarine était son oncle
préférées elle nous raconte le jour où
il s'est envolé dans le cosmos en 1961
telle qu'elle l'a vécue à 14 ans en
classe un matin ensoleillé est amiable
par papa et à prévenir les vestes euros
à l'époque l'espace c'était comme un
trou noir béant qui pouvait nous a valu
mais quand régime a annoncé qu'il était
revenu sain et sauf après 108 minutes de
vol c'était l'euphorie totale
c'est à venir mali certains grammages
inédits tels le premier homme dans
l'espace était un des nombreux
je suis issu du terroir au saint homme
ordinaire comme il y en a des millions
en urss des gagarine dans cette rare
entrevue
de simples fils de menuisier a star
mondiale le premier cosmonaute devient
l'icône de la plus grande campagne de
propagande de l'histoire de l'union ce
beat
reçu en héros dans 30 pays
ambassadeur du modèle soviétique en
pleine guerre froide d'historiens
alexander joe lesniak touche touche d
orgueil il était exceptionnel et ce que
gagarine a accompli pour l'humanité ne
pourra jamais être contestées la
personne demeure brillante grande
séduisant
mais bon
soixante ans plus tard il est un des
rares dont la légende et un tap les
russes il adore toutes générations
confondues et sa belle natale rebaptisé
gagarine ou incultes inégalée à tout ce
qu'il représente
c'était jour de fête quand nous y sommes
allés cet automne
les plus grands symboles de notre pays
sont pas par les cosmonautes dit artyom
15 ans qui dansent pour les invités
parmi eux plusieurs générations de
cosmonaute rue gagarine a expiré y
compris celles gates lui kalyev qu'on
appelle aussi le dernier soviétique
puisqu'il était dans l'espace quand
l'urss s'est effondré
l'exploit de gagarine ce qu'il a fait 20
au delà de l'urss et de la russie dick
hoffmann
[Musique]
reste qu'aujourd'hui son vol mythique
demeure un symbole pour le kremlin et sa
politique de grandeur de la russe
gagarine a été et il sera toujours d'une
historiette même si le programme spatial
russe n'est plus celui de l'urss qui a
propulsé le premier humain en orbite je
crois que on ne peut pas séparer
l'histoire de leur politique et
l'histoire de la russie contemporaine la
russie se définit surtout par ses
gloires du passé dit vladimir imana
gagarine pour nous
c'est
cet exemple
d'un homme
extraordinaire et comme tant de héros sa
fin sera tragique gagarine meurt à 34
ans en pilotant un vol d'essai sans
jamais avoir remis le pied dans l'espace
il fallait protéger le cosmonaute numéro
un 10 agnès et bien que iouri rêvait au
cosmos le régime l'en a privé comme on
disait à l'époque communiste son visage
son courage et son charisme son symbole
de la jeunesse éternelle
ici comme partout en russie gagarine est
immortel